else it's the same idea with when you
hear about stereotypes and gender is a
social construct and it's reinforced by
the clothes we wear the fact that we say
things like pink is a girl's color and
blue is a boy's color and boys like cars
and trucks and fighting and girls like
dolls and gardening and and baking if
that's the case that how you dress your
interests has nothing to do with your
gender then the whole transgender thing
falls apart because if gender is just
how you feel in the inside and how you
present on the outside has nothing to do
with it then why is it men who want to
be women wear dresses if the external
side the materialistic things is just a
social construct and things we've
invented stereotypes then why why do it
the whole thing just makes completely no
sense to me